-David Blaine,
great to see you, bud.
-Great to see you.
-I'm always happy to see you.
I'm always a little nervous
when I see you and anxious
but always in a good way.
I mean, we've been through --
We've seen you --
I've sewed your lips shut
with a needle and thread.
-Well, let's try simple.
Let's try something simple.
-Okay.
Okay.
-Do you want to take out
the numbers or the pictures?
Number cards or picture cards?
-Uh, uh, uh, uh...
Uh, pictures.
-Okay.
-Yeah.
-So, the pictures,
you have the Jacks,
the Queens, or the Kings.
Which ones do you want?
You decide.
-I like Jacks.
-Okay.
The Jacks, you have a red Jack
or a black Jack.
Reds or blacks?
Which one do you want?
-I'm gonna say a black Jack.
-By the way, you can change
your mind at any point.
I don't want you to think
that I'm making you say this.
Do you want to change?
-No, I'll stick with black Jack.
-Oh, you're good.
-So, the black Jacks,
you have clubs or spades.
Which one do you want?
-I'll do clubs.
-By the way, nobody ever
changes, but you can.
But it's up to you.
-[ Laughing ]
-You're so in my head right now.
-I just want this to be fair.
So if you want to change
to the other one, you can.
You can do whatever you want.
-Okay, great.
Then I will change.
-To which one?
-I will say, uh --
-You want to go to
the spade or the club or...?
-I'll say -- I'll say --
I'll say the spade.
-Are you sure?
Do you want to change back?
-No, Jack of spades.
-You're sure?
-Yes.
-Well, look, here,
I just want to show you
something funny in the deck.
Here it is.
See, there's one card
that's a little different
than all the others.
And you can see, look,
the one card that' different
is in the middle, and it's --
see that one card?
It's a Jack of spades.
-[ Laughing ]
But, Jimmy -- Jimmy --
No, but, Jimmy, listen to me.
It's possible
that I did some sleight of hand.
When I was removing
the cards in the box,
maybe I flicked it
really fast, correct?
-Sure.
-No, it's not possible.
'Cause this, the Jack of spades,
is the only red card
in this deck.
See?
Not only is it the only
red card in the deck,
but you're thinking, like,
"Oh, wait.
Maybe he convinced me.
Maybe..."
There's no other card
that would have worked.
Only the Jack of spades
would have worked...
-Yeah.
-...from the very beginning.
Look.
The whole deck...is blank.
-[ Laughing, clapping ]
-And that's...
I mean...
-Dude, you're unbelievable, man.
That is insanity.
-So, hold on.
I'm gonna --
You can see all the cards.
You can see all of the cards
in the deck.
You can see
they're all different, yes?
-Yes.
-So you thought of
a Jack of spades but you changed
from the Jack of clubs.
But now I want you
to think of a new card
that would be your favorite card
but one that I could never know.
-Okay.
-[ Coughs ]
-[ Laughs ]
-Wait. But, Jimmy...
What was the card
that you were thinking of?
-It was different card.
It was 8 of hearts.
-Oh, yeah, good.
That worked.
-[ Laughing ]
-[ Chuckles ]
-Oh, my...gosh!
Gosh!
-But you know the --
But, Jimmy, you know that
when you think of cards,
like, any card
that you would think of,
I would be able to produce.
-Yeah.
-Doesn't make a difference.
-I don't know how --
-You know, like, any card
that you would choose --
-I don't -- I don't know how.
I don't know how.
-Do you want me to tell you how?
-Sure.
-You want me to tell you how?
-No. Do I?
-The reason I can
spit your card out of my mouth
is because
I have a secret assistant.
You might remember him.
He's grown a bit
since the last time you saw him.
-It's not a frog.
Please, no.
Oh, my God.
Please don't do this.
No, it's not.
You're not doing this.
[ Laughing ]
[ Laughing, rapping desk,
papers crumpling ]
[ Laughing ]
What is going on?
You have to
stop doing that, man.
That is un --
-This is my magical assistant.
See.
-Oh, my gosh.
-He hands you different cards.
He's a very good -- oh, my gosh.
David, he's grow--
He's getting bi--
Oh, my God.
David Blaine, we have
to talk about your new special,
"The Ascension."
It's on YouTube August 31st.
From what I've heard about
"David Blaine: Ascension"
is that --
[ Laughing ]
-Sorry.
There was another one.
[ Both laugh ]
-Oh!
Oh, my gosh.
[ Breathes deeply ]
You have two assistants.
-Yeah.
No, but, so --
[ Laughs ]
So, the new one
that I'm working on,
it's called "Ascension,"
and the goal is I want to
take a bunch of balloons
and just float up into the sky
until I vanish.
My dream has always been --
Looking up into the sky,
it would be amazing to just --
like the movie
"Le ballon rouge,"
just grab a bunch of balloons
and go drifting away.
So I've been diligently
putting this together,
and I have an amazing team.
And working with YouTube
has allowed me to kind of
just put together
this insane idea.
-And hopefully
you're doing this safely.
I mean, what --
-Yeah, we're doing it safely.
And I've been practicing,
and I had to get
a hot-air-balloon pilot license.
I got my gas restriction lifted
so I could fly
helium-filled balloons,
which is pretty rare, actually.
And I've been
jumping out of airplanes
to get comfortable in the air.
-Really?
Will you have a parachute
or anything?
What if the balloons pop?
-Yeah. Well, I would have one
up in the balloons.
'Cause I -- I want it to be
the image of just
a boy holding
a bunch of balloons
and drifting away
like the movie that I saw.
So I want it to be simplistic.
-I understand what
you want it to look like.
You can always draw it.
You don't have to do it.
-[ Laughs ]
So, behind me is some of the --
We're in the warehouse,
actually.
Behind me
is enough of the balloons
that my daughter would --
This is enough to float
my daughter right here.
So this is just
a little bit of the rig
which we're gonna be using.
And then obviously, for me,
it's much --
a much bigger rig.
And I'd say,
with 20 more of those balloons,
I would go floating
all the way up
and disappear into the sky
legitimately.
But, of course, anything over,
you know, 18,000 feet gets --
becomes more and more dangerous
because the temperatures drop,
and you can become hypoxic
and things like that.
So I've been practicing
and learning all of that.
-This is August 31st this is
happening, live on YouTube.
-Depending on the winds.
[ Laughs ]
-Okay.
So, weather permitting, okay.
'Cause you don't
want to end up --
-Weather permitting.
[ Both laugh ]
-You're gonna end up
in California again,
and you're gonna go, "Wait. What
happened to David Blaine?"
"Oh, he's still floating.
Yeah."
I cannot wait to see this.
I'm psyched for you.
Check out
"David Blaine: Ascension,"
streaming live on YouTube
in just a few weeks,
August 31st, weather permitting.
David,
you're always a great guest.
Please be safe, buddy.
I want to see you again, okay?
-Thank you,
and thanks for having me again.
Good to see you.